In the world of supercars, the Lamborghini Sian FKP 37 is unique.
The dynamic lines, audacious angles, sleek curves make it so futuristic.
And yet, it's still unmistakably Lamborghini.
We spent over a year trying to recreate this in a 1 to 8 scale LEGO Technic model,...
...working closely with the design team at Lamborghini,...
...getting all the details and lines as perfect as we could.
At the end of such a project, you're always thinking, "What more could we do?"
"How can we keep this great collaboration going?"
After speaking to the design team in Sant'Agata, Lamborghini's headquarters,...
...we came up with the idea of going big...
...and creating a full-size, 1 to 1 scale version of the Sian FKP 37.
Though our car was always going to have the same green color as the 1 to 8 scale model,...
...we felt it needed a touch of something special to make it unique.
Here, the Lamborghini designers suggested using the skilled craftsmen...
...who paint their cars to do something with ours.
Watching the craftsman adding the layer of color to the LEGO Technic elements...
...was like watching an artist at work.
There is only going to be 63 Sian FKP 37s made and every one will be unique.
The idea of making ours unique as well was difficult to resist.
From there, everything moved quickly:...
...the final builds, the small details, the test of the electronics.
Our dream had come true.
The full-size LEGO Technic version of the Lamborghini Sian FKP 37 was complete.
How did we do?
It's really not up to us to say.
It's the LEGO fans and the supercar enthusiasts that will decide.
But, we're proud of the car.